but when he says give them hell
Netanyahu give them hell you are trying
to Advocate the genocide of millions of
people imagine living for decades under
an open air prison where everything you
do is controlled from what you eat to
what you drink brothers and sisters
please donate as we have come together
one umah to get the necessary Aid needed
to Palestine and Gaza keep them in your
duas but specifically brother and
sisters give from what you love
inshallah and love for your brothers and
sisters what you love for yourself
donate now inah whatever you can and
allow us to reach that Aid with one umah
to our brothers and sisters in Palestine
one day Palestine will be free I came
across a video of Andrew Tate and his
brother sitting at a table sub his
brother's a Christian he himself is a
Muslim and Subhan Allah you can see that
even they are you know calling out what
they see Subhan Allah and even though
they don't they're don't not really
clued up about the matter Etc but the
matter at hand is the following that
this is what Andrew T had to say about
Jordan Peterson Jordan Peterson is a
double standard hypocritical scum what I
will call who has literally said give
him hell to Netanyahu a war criminal I
mean just imagine for a moment if I was
to do a video like that and talking
about be the Taliban or be it Isis or
anyone for that matter because Israel is
a terrorist State and if I said to them
you know give them hell today I will be
locked
up locked up and I would never ever see
de again my accounts would be shut I
would disappear but it's okay the white
man like himself who cannot go to sleep
without pills and may Allah subhana wa
tala make him live hell on Earth the way
he wishes it on the innocent pales
who've been occupied for the past 75
years here's what Andrew Tate had to say
let's watch this and let's come back
insh you become pretty anti-war and I
find it extremely asinine and quite
childish hypocritical and also
disingenuine that people like Peterson
will call for the genocide and call for
war when truthfully he would hate to be
anywhere near a war for him to sit and
try and Advocate destruction when he
himself can't hand handle Twitter haters
and needs absolute peace of mind let
alone peace of physicality to sleep at
night without drugs I find that quite
disingenuine I also find it very
shortsighted so when we look at the
right-wing American freeth thinkers but
when he says give them hello give them
hell you are trying to Advocate the
genocide of millions of people pawns who
do not move pieces on the chess board
they have no power innocent people who
are just trying to go about and live
their lives because somebody else has
made a move on the board is that fair to
the person who gets bombed and loses
their family no same on the other side
the average Israeli the average person
who's living in a Border Town who gets
shot pawns on the chessboard I'm smart
enough to look at this situation and
understand what's really happening which
is that I don't know and none of the
people with strong opinions truly know
so guys you saw what he had to say
Subhan Allah and it is exactly what
Andre T said that he is calling for
genocide on the Muslims I mean you
cannot be a big Subhan Allah like we
never ever saw him as an ally anyways
but the brothers aldah had opportunity
to give him da to talk with him where he
had to say what do you mean by this and
what you mean by that what does that
mean you know can he acting dumb and it
seems like he was so hurt and humiliated
by the occurring I had with from Brother
mam Andes who welcomed him and sat with
him but you can see deep deep down deep
deep down Allah subhana wa tala tells us
the psychology of the Christian the Jew
the mush the M yes and even those
certain Muslims who can become hostile
to other believers Allah tells us about
their psychology and that Allah subhana
told this many times to us but we will
not believe it and we will suck up the
people like Jordan Peterson and I'm
talking about those who actually suck up
not those who gave him an opportunity to
give him da like brother mamed andam
daugh aldah who welcomed him and looked
after him Subhan Allah tells us that do
not take them as intimate friends and
this in itself is an Evidence to that in
the Battle of bad you saw the same thing
in the Battle of you saw the same thing
you had Brothers you had brothers and
brothers or brothers fighting their
fathers why because we say blood is
thicker than water meaning blood bond
between each other yes but we believe
Iman is thicker than blood and you see
this brother and sisters when it comes
to push comes to sh that believe me the
true people that care about you are no
one but the Believers yes this does not
mean we are not good and kind to
Christians and Jews no no no it just
means that we do not and we should not
take anybody as intimate friends except
the Believers Subhan Allah and this is
what it showed you and this coward this
coward who had to go to rehab who
couldn't sleep without pills may Allah
subhana wa ta'ala may God Almighty make
you live and taste hell which you are
already on Earth yes and if you don't
change in the Hereafter for calling hell
asking Netanyahu to bomb and literally
Massacre innocent Palestinians who have
been under oppression for 75 years but
when it comes to the issue of Russia and
Ukraine what utter double standard
alhamdulillah people have seen your true
face and they have seen it once and for
all I want to thank brother Andrew Tate
for calling this double standard scum of
a human being no backbone coward that's
what you are shame on you and brothers
and sisters like Andrew Tate and his
brother said they donate to help the
poor and needy there is a link in the
description box we are working with one
um inshallah to raise funds to Aid our
brothers and sisters in Palestine with
your funds but also Wen up for faud if
you do not wake up for faud forget the
protest forget the damn protest if you
really care about your brother sisters
wake up for faud and if you do wake up
and you do your five Day prayers and
make du for them may Allah subhana
preserve you guys and bless you guys and
may Allah subhana T give Victory to the
Palestinians
alhamdulillah the victory will come
inshallah in a way and again we condemn
anyone for that matter we don't want to
see any innocent soul in Islam be it the
Jews the Christians the Muslims the
Hindus whoever it is against our
religion severely to harm innocent
people Subhan Allah that's all I want to
say in may Allah bless you
guys Palestine will be free